hallo wir drehen heute ein video im es
gibt verschiedene arten zu schwimmen
das ist frust schwimmen
das nennt sich kraulen matthias kaul
durch den pool
es gibt auch rückenschwimmen matthias
schwimmt auf dem rücken
matthias es gibt auch eine richtige
technik zum rückenschwimmen matthias
schwimmt wie ein hund sehr gut fand erst
das machst du wirklich sehr gut matthias
hat seine sonnenbrille im pool verloren
er muss tauchen matthias taucht nach der
sonnenbrille
er hat seine sonnenbrille wieder
matthias und alle pflanzen im pool alle
hat matthias gesetz auf österreichisch
heißt dass alle hat mattiert gedümpelt
jetzt gibt es rache matthias taucht
unter er ist jetzt unter wasser unter
wasser muss er die luft anhalten
jetzt sitzt matthias auf dem grund des
pools er versucht unter wasser zu
meditieren
das hat aber nicht so lange gedauert
matthias möchte vom einen ende zum
anderen ende des pools taufen
er probiert es matthias taucht durch den
pool
er schwimmt auch noch unter wasser
zurück markiert kann aber sehr lange die
luft anhalten
ich bin wirklich schwer beeindruckt
sauber matthias gut gemacht
matthias ich habe das gefühl dass alle
schwimm- vokabeln im österreichischen
ganz anders sind als in deutschen ja
also die wörter die suche sagt hass habe
ich noch nie gehört
ok ich sag kein wort auf deutsch und du
aus österreich schwimmen schwimmen
tauchen paucken einen körper machen
einen fonds einen köpfler macht jemanden
deppen jemanden fünfteln ein arzt bombe
machen 84 macht einen körper in den pool
ich bin nass geworden
jetzt macht mattiert eine arschbombe in
den pool
na ja da hast du das gemacht matthias
ganz toll ich bin sehr beeindruckt mal
alles ist nass geworden
das war super easy german aus dem pool
hast du spaß gehabt
ich habe es geliebt gehst du gerne
schwimmen sehr gerne
matthias schwimmt jetzt weiter und wir
verabschieden uns
[Musik]
[Applaus]